nos vamos hasta Bruselas Ahí está
nuestra corresponsal Esther Herrera
Esther la saludo muy buena tarde y que
es lo último sobre lo que acaba de
ocurrir la destitución de Eva cae
Sí así es Buenos días luz verde de la
eurocámara para destituir a Eva Kylie
una de las vicepresidentas de la
eurocámara Kylie está emprutada por un
supuesto caso de corrupción por haber
recibido Regalos y también dinero
supuestamente por Qatar para influir
positivamente en la imagen de este país
en la institución con 625 votos a favor
un voto prácticamente unánime en la
eurocámara han votado para que Eva cae
ya no sea vicepresidenta de la
institución con efecto inmediato por
considerar que ha cometido una falta
grave Kylie ya fue destituido del grupo
socialista ayer precisamente el grupo
socialdemócrata anunció que se personará
como parte perjudicada en el proceso
judicial Kylie a través de su abogado
defendido su inocencia y que nada tiene
que ver con este supuesto caso de
corrupción Aunque según Las
investigaciones se encontró en su
domicilio más de 150.000 euros Además de
que su padre se le encontró con está
llena de dinero que está en libertad sin
cargos este escándalo ha dejado en
estado de shock a las instituciones
europeas la presidenta de la eurocámara
Robert tametzola ha anunciado una
investigación interna además de revisar
el código de conducta entre los
eurodiputados y los grupos en depresión
Kylie es la cabeza más visible de esta
supuesta trama de corrupción se
encuentra en prisión a las afueras de
bruselasses espera que mañana pase a
declarar ante el juez también está
acusado su pareja y dos personas más que
forman parte de organizaciones que
luchan por los Derechos Humanos